[Applaus]
ein 14-stöckiger Hochhauskomplex mit 156
Wohnungen gebaut in nur 51 Tagen um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen arbeiten die
Bauarbeiter in drei Schichten Tag und
Nacht was in 24 Stunden müssen wir vier
Wohnungen fertig haben und mit den
nächsten beginnen so ein turbo-bau ist
nur möglich wenn die Fabrik alle Teile
pünktlich liefert und die Bauarbeiter
sie sofort installieren
wir haben nur eine Stunde Zeit um die
gelieferten Teile zu montieren wenn wir
länger brauchen bringen wir die gesamte
Bauplanung durcheinander
was man allerdings nicht planen kann ist
das Wetter heftige Böden setzen der
Baustelle zu
okay gut so
trocken Wind und Temperaturen von -20°,
muss die Arbeit weitergehen denn der
Hochhauskomplex soll in nur 51
Arbeitstagen fertig sein
[Musik]
Moskau
Russlands Hauptstadt ist mit rund 13
Millionen Einwohnern die größte Stadt
Europas und jedes Jahr kommen mehr
Menschen dazu
wie in allen mega Städten ist es fast
unmöglich in Moskau bezahlbaren Wohnraum
zu finden die Regierung hat darum ein
massives Wohnungsbauprogramm auf den Weg
gebracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
innerhalb der nächsten Jahre sollen 65
Millionen Quadratmeter neuer Wohnraum
entstehen mehr als eine Million neue
Wohnungen
Bauunternehmen ziehen daher ein Hochhaus
nach dem anderen in die Höhe einen
Vertrag ergattert jedoch nur wer
schnelle Arbeit verspricht und liefert
eine der größten Baustellen liegt am
südlichen Rand der russischen Hauptstadt
etwa 30 km vom Zentrum entfernt
das Betonfundament für den
mega-pop-abbau ist bereits gegossen es
ist 72 m lang
und 15 Meter breit
innerhalb von nur 51 Werktagen sollen
hier 156 neue Wohnungen mit einer
Gesamtfläche von 9000 Quadratmetern
entstehen
[Applaus]
in 24 Stunden soll hier der Bau des 14
stückigen Hochhauses beginnen
Projektleiter sophianov ist merklich
angespannt bevor die Arbeiten auf der
Mega Baustelle beginnen hat er noch viel
Kleinkram auf seinem Zettel
Preis
wir sind gerade dabei die erste Bauphase
vorzubereiten
die Arbeiter müssen die Positionen der
Mauern markieren
und dann müssen wir Vorkehrungen für die
Nachtschicht treffen
also zum Beispiel Baustrahler
installieren weil wir ja auch nachts
arbeiten
wenn wir damit fertig sind müssen wir
die Geräte für die Schweißer an den
Start bringen
Sophie Janov und sein Team haben für
jedes Stockwerk also für 12 Wohnungen
nur drei Tage Zeit
diesen engen Zeitplan können sie nur
dank einer speziellen Bautechnik
Einhalten der Plattenbauweise
einzelne Elemente wie Wände und Decken
werden als Beton Fertigteile in Fabriken
vorbereitet und müssen vor Ort nur noch
zusammengefügt werden
die Baustelle ist in drei Abschnitte
unterteilt in der erste Abschnitt
fertiggestellt ist wird mit dem nächsten
begonnen dadurch können andere
Handwerker wie Elektriker Installateure
Klempner und Verputzer in den bereits
fertigen Abschnitten loslegen
Beweise arbeiten sich die Bauarbeiter
Stockwerk für Stockwerk nach oben
die komplette erste Etage ist eine
Bauzeit von 96 Stunden veranschlagt
Projektleiter als fahren so viel Januar
hat zwar fast 20 Jahre Erfahrung auf dem
Buckel aber dieses Projekt fließt ihn
noch Respekt ein
es ist ein gigantisches Projekt
wir arbeiten hier mit sehr großen und
sehr schweren teilenstiel
[Musik]
vor allem der Beginn ist kompliziert
wir müssen absolut präzise sein sonst
fällt uns das später auf die Füße
[Musik]
selbst ein kleiner Fehler kann uns
später große Probleme bereiten
Keller und Erdgeschoss sind mit
Stahlbeton bewährt um den Baum maximale
Stabilität zu geben
morgen werden die Arbeiter des erste
mauermodul des 14 stöckigen Hauses über
den Erdgeschoss installieren
auch alle weiteren Mauerteile müssen
Zentimeter genau platziert werden
Vermesser Vladimir billig und seine
Kollegen zeichnen daher über 300
Markierungen ein
so wurden
detaillierten Bauzeichnung
mit Hilfe der Pläne markieren wir jetzt
alle Stellen auf dem Fundament so das
klar ist wo was hinkommt
auf die entsprechenden Markierungen man
kann die ja nicht hinstellen wohin man
will
Raum für Irrtümer gibt es nicht selbst
der kleinste Fehler kann dazu führen
dass die Mauern später nicht
zusammenpassen
das Anzeichen ist extrem wichtig die
Männer müssen sehr präzise arbeiten nur
dann werden auch die nächsten Schritte
Gelingen
jeder Fehler der jetzt passiert wird den
gesamten Bau beeinträchtigen
[Musik]
für zeitraubende Korrekturen gibt es
schlicht keine Zeit schließlich ist dies
kein normales Bauprojekt
sophianov und sein Team wollen hier ein
45 m hohes Gebäude in gerade einmal 51
Arbeitstagen hochziehen das ist dreimal
schneller als bei einem konventionellen
Bau
[Musik]
eines der wichtigsten Geräte auf der
mega-baustelle ist der 60 Meter hohe
Kran er kann bis zu 10 Tonnen anheben
und gleitet auf Schienen über die
Baustelle
damit der Kran auch die letzte Ecke der
Baustelle erreichen kann müssen die
Arbeiter einen kleineren Kran abbauen
und die Schienen des größeren um 35m
verlängern
zuerst verdichten die Arbeiter den Boden
unter den Schienen ansonsten würde er
unter dem Gewicht des Krans einsacken
die Männer stehen unter Zeitdruck
die Schienen müssen fertig verlegt sein
bevor der Kran das erste Mauersegment am
Haken hat so dass er es gleich an die
gewünschte Stelle heben kann
alexander schickenowski ist
Stellvertreter und rechter Hand von
Projektleiter Sophia Lauf er baut seit
fast 30 Jahren Wohnhochhäuser
jetzt haben wir ein Problem
warum hast du es dorthin gestellt
nur noch 20 Stunden bis Baubeginn wenn
der Kran bis dahin nicht einsatzbereit
ist droht Zeitverzug und das wäre eine
Katastrophe für einen pop-up-bau wie
diesen
sagen
bei so einem Projekt müssen die
Vorbereitungen perfekt sein
idealerweise hat man alle Module und die
ganze Ausrüstung schon ein paar Tage
vorher auf der Baustelle
und wenn es losgeht haben wir keine
Minute zu verschenken
Zeitplan wie diesem hier ist es sehr
schwer auch nur wenige Stunden wieder
aufzuholen
die größte Herausforderung ist die
Logistik nur wenn alle Materialien in
der richtigen Reihenfolge und zur
richtigen Zeit ausgeliefert werden
können die Bauarbeiter den engen
Zeitrahmen einhalten
deswegen arbeiten wir mit fünf Tonnen
Zylindern
einer von ihnen reicht gerade mal für 24
Stunden wir haben einen Container mit
zementpulver und einen mit Wasser beides
wird gemischt und dann kommt der fertige
Beton da unten raus
je frischer de Beton desto einfach alles
dass ich verarbeiten nach nur einer
Stunde beginnt er auszuhärten
doch vorbaubeginn gibt es noch viel zu
tun es gibt keine Pause die Männer
müssen über Nacht durcharbeiten
der nächste Morgen noch sechs Stunden
bevor es losgehen soll
doch heute ist es sehr windig selbst für
Moskauer Verhältnisse
Projektleiter sophie janoff ist besorgt
denn bei starkem Wind kann er den Kran
nicht einsetzen
ich hoffe dass uns das Wetter nicht in
die Quere kommt
laut Wettervorhersage soll es windig
werden
im Moment geht's aber gerade noch
ab einer Windgeschwindigkeit von 15
Metern pro Sekunde was Windstärke 7 auf
der bofortskala entspricht stellt sich
der Kran automatisch ab denn dann
besteht die Gefahr dass seilerreissen
oder er im schlimmsten Fall sogar
umkippen könnte sollte jetzt ein Sturm
aufziehen dann müsste das Team den lang
geplanten Baustart verschieben
noch machen alle weiter wie vorgesehen
in der Hoffnung pünktlich zu starten die
Lieferung der mauersegmente ist
wochenlang geplant worden eine
Verschiebung würde die minutiös
ausgearbeitete Logistik über den Haufen
werfen
ich mache gerade die letzten Chats ich
muss alles überprüfen z.B ob das Ganze
Werkzeug da ist und ob die Bauwagen gut
ausgestattet sind
in den verbleibenden Stunden müssen die
Männer die Baustelle einrichten Ordnung
machen und die kranschienen fertig
verlegen
[Musik]
noch eine Stunde bis zum anvisierten
Start auf dem Fundament ist alles
vorbereitet
anders sieht es direkt daneben aus noch
fehlen zehn Meter Schienen für den Kran
das Problem das Verdichten des Bodens
hat länger gedauert als geplant und
solange die Schienen nicht liegen können
die Bauarbeiten nicht beginnen
[Musik]
ich will das hier in einer halben Stunde
alles fertig ist damit wir weitermachen
können
Projektleiter auf trommelt alle
verfügbaren Arbeiter zusammen denn ohne
den riesigen Baukran können Sie die
Wände nicht an Ort und Stelle platzieren
vor dem geplanten Baubeginn ist auch der
Kran einsatzfähig
alles ist vorbereitet jetzt warten wir
nur noch auf die Wandsegmente dann
können wir loslegen
die Arbeiten an dem gigantischen
pop-up-gebäude können beginnen in nur 51
Tagen soll hier ein Wohnkomplex mit 156
neuen Apartments entstehen um Moskaus
Wohnungsnot zu lindern
der Countdown beginnt die letzten
Sekunden vor dem Start
[Musik]
aber dann
nichts
alles ist vorbereitet
doch das Wichtigste fehlt
die mauersegmente sind noch nicht
angekommen und ohne Mauern kein Haus
[Musik]
einige Teile sind bereits eingetroffen
aber nur welche die wir jetzt noch nicht
brauchen etwa Teile für das
Lüftungssystem
die Wandelemente und andere Teile werden
von der Fabrik just in time geliefert
das spart Kosten für die Lagerung Zeit
und Platz auf der Baustelle doch die
Strategie ist riskant selbst kleinste
Verspätungen können alles durcheinander
bringen so wie jetzt
die Fabrik die die Fertigteilplatten
herstellt befindet sich nördlich von
Moskau
schon vor Tagen hatten die Arbeiter hier
mit dem Bau der Mauerelemente begonnen
von hier aus sollen sie in der richtigen
Reihenfolge zur Baustelle transportiert
werden jeder Lastwagenfahrer erhält eine
Chipkarte aus der hervorgeht welche
Teile in welcher Reihenfolge geladen
werden müssen
ein Risikofaktor bei der Zeitplanung ist
der Verkehr in Moskau die 45 km lange
Fahrt bis zur Baustelle kann mit unter 3
Stunden dauern
es ist früher Abend die Bauarbeiten
hätten vor drei Stunden beginnen sollen
doch bisher ist nichts passiert
dann aber trudeln endlich die Laster mit
den ersten Mauerteilen ein
sie haben vier Elemente geladen die
nächsten sollen in einer Stunde kommen
die Männer müssen sich anhalten
die Bauarbeiten erinnern an Tetris für
riesen das Konzept geht nur auf wenn die
Teile in der richtigen Reihenfolge an
den richtigen Stellen positioniert
werden
die Außenmauern mit den integrierten
Fenstern werden zuerst installiert dann
kommen die Innenwände und die
Treppenhäuser dann das fertige bereits
geflieste Badezimmer samt Badewanne
zum Schluss die Deckenelemente
oben an den Wänden sind Haken integriert
so dass der Kran sie leicht anheben kann
das Wandelement wird auf eine 10 cm
dicke Betonschicht gestellt sie soll die
Mauer in Position halten
es ist extrem windig aber die
Bauarbeiter lassen sich davon nicht
beirren nur 10 Minuten nachdem die
ersten Trucks eingetroffen sind wird die
erste Wand gestellt
drei Männer arbeiten bei diesem
Arbeitsschritt mit
Projektleiter Sophie jana hat dafür
seine besten Leute abgestellt die seit
fast 20 Jahren in der Firma beschäftigt
sind
[Musik]
eine weise Entscheidung denn trotz
Zeitdruck und schlechtem Wetter behalten
Sie einen kühlen Kopf es bleibt sogar
noch Zeit für eine typisch russische
Tradition
das ist ein sehr alter Brauch
wenn man ein Haus baut legt man eine
Münze unter die Außenmauern
Naturgewalten und beschert den Bewohnern
des Hauses Reichtum Glück und Liebe
und was immer sie sich sonst noch
wünschen
nachdem die Münze verbaut wurde steht
nun die erste von fast 1500 Mauern dann
geht es gleich weiter mit der nächsten
die Bauarbeiter wollen die dreistündige
Verzögerung aufholen so gut es geht
je nach Größe wiegen die Elemente
zwischen 2,5 und 7 Tonnen
die Männer bringen das nächste Element
zwischen den Markierungen grob in
Position
dann stabilisieren sie es mit
Stahlstützen
wenn der Beton nach einigen Stunden
ausgehärtet ist entfernen Sie die
Stützen und flexen die Metallhaken mit
einem Winkelschleifer ab
dann folgt das Feintuning
Arbeiter sergeykin kontrolliert ob die
Mauern vollkommen senkrecht stehen und
richtet sie Zentimeter genau an den
Markierungen aus
ich kontrolliere die Position auf dem
Fundament
die Mauer muss genau 20 cm Abstand zu
den Markierungen haben
sobald die Mauer in Position ist tritt
der Schweißer auf den Plan er befestigt
sie mit Hilfe spezieller Eisenklammern
am Boden später werden die Löcher
gefüllt
[Musik]
jetzt da die Lieferung angelaufen ist
geht die Arbeit schnell voran
das einzige was uns jetzt noch einen
Strich durch die Rechnung machen könnte
ist der Wind
wenn der zu stark wird kann es
gefährlich werden
und wir müssen abbrechen
tatsächlich hat der Wind
zwischenzeitlich aufgefrischt immer
wieder Peitschen heftige Böhlen über die
Baustelle
ausgerechnet als sie eines der größten
Segmente anheben passiert es ein sieben
Tonnen schweres Element läuft Gefahr
außer Kontrolle zu geraten im
schlimmsten Fall könnten die Stahlseile
durch die Drehung reißen und das
mauerelement zu bodenkrachen
ja setzt die Mauer für einen Moment auf
den Boden wir heben sie gleich rüber
so ist es gut
die fünf Meter lange Mauer ist unter
Kontrolle
doch sie in Position zu bringen ist
nicht so einfach es bedarf einer
konzertierten Aktion um das zu schaffen
endlich steht die Wand am Ende ist alles
gut gegangen doch sollte es so windig
bleiben müssen sie pausieren und würden
kostbare Zeit verlieren
zum Glück lässt der Wind etwas nach und
die Männer können sich wieder ans Werk
machen
bis zum Schichtende in sechs Stunden
müssen die Arbeiter weitere 17
Außenmauern sitzen das heißt eine alle
20 Minuten
noch 49 Tage die Männer haben die
Verzögerungen vom Anfang wieder
aufgeholt die Außenmauern im ersten
Stock stehen und die Außenwände für den
mittleren Abschnitt sind bereits an Ort
und Stelle
die Nachtschicht hat gerade begonnen
ihre Aufgabe alle 22 Innenwände in der
Mittelsektion zu installieren so dass
anschließend die Decken montiert werden
können
[Musik]
die Innenwände sind im Laufe des Tages
wie geplant aus der Fabrik geliefert
worden bis sie verbaut werden lagert das
Team sie in speziell gefertigten Rahmen
Nachtschicht Vorarbeiter Sergej miaskov
kontrolliert sie auf etwaige
Transportschäden schon ein kleiner Riss
könnte die Stabilität des ganzen
Gebäudes Gefährten
diese Elemente kommen in den ersten
Stock sie müssen vor Ende unserer
Schicht installiert werden dann sind wir
mit dem Innenbereich dieses Abschnitts
fertig
jedes Element ist mit einer Nummer
versehen die Männer gleichen diese
Nummern mit denen in den
Konstruktionszeichnungen ab um sie dann
entsprechend zu platzieren
bist du schon in Bewegung
die Innenwände werden nach dem gleichen
Prinzip gestellt wie die Außenwände
auch hier müssen die Arbeiter die genaue
Platzierung sorgsam überprüfen das
Zusammenfügen der Elemente gleicht einem
riesigen Puzzle wenn die Männer an einer
Stelle einen Fehler machen passt es an
anderer Stelle nicht mehr zusammen
erst wenn alle Elemente da sind wo sie
hingehören werden sie mit Hilfe von
Stahlklammern befestigt
zunächst geht bei den Innenwänden alles
glatt
doch dann kommt ein Lastwagen der
Aussenmauern geladen hat nur wo soll man
die lagern die fassadenziegel sind sehr
empfindlich und könnten Schaden nehmen
nachtschichtvorarbeiter Silke kiaskov
muss Plan B aus dem Hut zaubern
die Fabrik hat uns gerade Wände für den
zweiten Stock geliefert das heißt wir
müssen jetzt vom ersten in den zweiten
Stock umziehen und da weitermachen wir
haben nur eine Stunde Zeit um den
Lastwagen zu entladen wenn wir länger
brauchen Gerät die ganze Logistik
durcheinander
der Lastwagen muss so schnell wie
möglich zurück in die Fabrik für die
Arbeiter heißt das alles hinwerfen und
Vorbereitungen für das Aufstellen der
Wände treffen die gerade gekommen sind
[Applaus]
trotz der unerwarteten Planänderung
steht das erste Element nur 15 Minuten
nach Eintreffen des Lasters an Ort und
Stelle
unsere Männer arbeiten immer in Teams
mit dem gleichen Zeitplan
sie werden nicht hin und hergereicht
sobald wir hier fertig sind wird das
gesamte Team als Einheit zur nächsten
Baustelle weiterziehen
eine Strategie die sich auszahlt vor
allem in stressigen Situationen wie
heute
wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit um die
letzten beiden Teile zu installieren
Sergej ist Hauptaugenmerk liegt darauf
dass die Männer den Zeitplan einhalten
[Musik]
was sie auch tun der Laster ist entladen
die Männer brauchen nur 60 Minuten um
die unerwartete mauerlieferung zu
installieren
[Musik]
dann geht es weiter mit den planmäßigen
arbeiten
noch 15 weitere Innenwände müssen in den
nächsten fünf Stunden aufgestellt werden
sonst kann die nächste Schicht nicht mit
der Decke weitermachen
[Musik]
auch die folgenden Wochen arbeiten die
Männer rund um die Uhr auf der
mega-baustelle
mit jedem Stockwerk wächst das Hochhaus
um weitere drei Meter
das Ziel des Teams das gesamte Bauwerk
innerhalb der vorgesehenen 51 Tage
fertigstellen denn die ersten Bewohner
wollen bereits kurz danach einziehen
[Musik]
Halbzeit der 8 Stock soll morgen stehen
das Team hat noch 27 Tage Zeit um die
übrigen Stockwerke fertig zu stellen
stand jetzt sind die Arbeiten voll im
Zeitplan
[Musik]
doch es schneit seit mehreren Stunden
und die Temperaturen sind auf -8 Grad
gesunken das ist nicht nur sehr
unangenehm
sondern auch gefährlich
durch den Schnee kann der frische Beton
gefrieren was zerrissen führen kann
Schichtmeister andre und seine Kollegen
gucken daher besonders genau hin
im Moment ist es wegen des Wetters sehr
schwierig wir kommen nur langsam voran
weil wir ständig den Schnee beseitigen
müssen
hinzu kommt je höher ein Gebäude wird
desto länger sind die Arbeitswege doch
die Uhr tickt unbarmherzig weiter
von unten dringen die anderen Gewerke
bereits nach oben
im siebten Stock legen Elektriker die
Kabel für Licht und Steckdosen
ein Stockwerk tiefer in der sechsten
Etage installieren die Klempner
Leitungen für heiß und Kaltwasser in den
vorgefertigten Badezimmern
und noch ein Stockwerk tiefer sind die
Verputzer am Werk
jede Verzögerung beim Aufstellen der
neuen Wände würde eine Kettenreaktion
nach sich ziehen wenn ein Team ein
Stockwerk höher Probleme hat werden auch
alle nachfolgenden Arbeiten in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen
mit anderen Worten
Klempner können nur Rohre verschweißen
und Elektriker nur Kabel verlegen wenn
die Mauern auch stehen
normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme
aber hier ist es immer ziemlich hektisch
viel schlimmer als auf einer normalen
Baustelle
die Kabelkanäle sind bereits in den
wandsegmenten eingebaut der Elektriker
muss jetzt nur noch die Kabel
hindurchziehen immerhin zwei einhalb
Kilometer pro Stockwerk
in den Etagen darunter in denen die
Elektriker schweißer und Klempner
bereits fertig sind kommen jetzt die
Verputzer zum Zuge sie müssen etliche
Kilometer Fugen zwischen den Wandteilen
verputzen
in Russland ist das eine Arbeit die
traditionell von Frauen erledigt wird
und es ist das einzige Gewerk in dem man
hier Frauen antrifft der große Vorteil
dieser Arbeit es ist warm riesige
Heizlüfter helfen dabei dass der Putz
schneller trocknet
mehrmals am Tag kontrolliert Alexander
shikonowski die Arbeit der verschiedenen
Teams
miteinander verbunden sind jetzt kann
ich den nächsten trubarbeiter
reinschicken damit Sie alles zu machen
nicht nur die äußere Hülle muss bis zum
Ende der 51 Tage fertig sein sondern
auch die Elektrik die Klempner und
Putzarbeiten
als nächstes gucke ich wie weit der
Schweißer ist
einen guten Job gemacht hat
die verputzerinnen können erst anfangen
wenn die Schweißarbeiten erledigt sind
draußen geht die Arbeit trotz heftigen
Schneefalls unbeirrt weiter
jeden Tag kommen 30 lastwagenlieferungen
auf der Baustelle an die Arbeiter müssen
Sie so schnell wie möglich entladen denn
das Logistikkonzept der Baufirma geht
nur auf wenn die Laster ständig in
Bewegung sind
[Musik]
das verantwortliche Bauunternehmen
betreibt mehrere Fabriken die die
Mauerelemente herstellen
dieser Betrieb produziert seit rund 60
Jahren Außenwände
pro Woche steht die Firma fast 1.500
Wandelemente her
aufs Jahr hochgerechnet macht das rund
75.000 Wände
Elemente werden in einer
Fertigungsstraße produziert
momentan sind gerade die Balkone des
Hochhauses in Arbeit
zuerst kommt bewährungsstahl in die mit
Wandfliesen ausgelegte Form das sorgt
für die Stabilität der Wände genau wie
beim konventionellen Hausbau
an der nächsten Station wird die erste
lagebeton hinein gegossen auch hier ist
der Beton der gleiche der üblicherweise
bei anderen Gebäuden verwendet wird
Produktionsleiter Igor Pavlov
beaufsichtigt den Fertigungsprozess die
Mauern werden später nur zusammen passen
in die vorgegebenen Abmessungen genau
eingehalten werden
ich habe mir gerade die Stärke der
Mauern angesehen die erste Schicht darf
nicht dicker als 70 mm sein
zur besseren Isolierung wird dann dem
Material auf den Beton gelegt
und darauf kommt eine weitere
lagebewegung Stahl für extra Stabilität
die letzte Schicht besteht aus
grobkörnigem bleibt
die Mauern die wir herstellen
entsprechend höchsten Qualitätsstandards
und halten bis zu 100 Jahre
nach zwei Stunden ist die Mauer fast
fertig
ein letzter Feinschliff und dann geht es
in die unterirdische Trocknungskammer
hier Härten die Wände bei 52 Grad
Celsius 5 Stunden lang aus
[Musik]
dann werden die Paneele fertiggestellt
indem die Arbeiter noch Fenster einbauen
danach können die Elemente ausgeliefert
werden
drück auf der Baustelle noch immer haben
die Leute vor Ort mit Schnee und
Minusgraden zu kämpfen in 26 Tagen
müssen sie fertig sein
ihr Etappenziel heute die Decke in der
achten Etage installieren
anschließend wird die Nachtschicht mit
dem neunten Stock beginnen
oben beginnen die Arbeiter die noch
fehlenden Deckenelemente einzusetzen
auch sie bestehen aus Stahlbeton
[Musik]
die Arbeiter installieren Sie nach einem
ähnlichen Prinzip wie die Wände die
Paneele werden mit Beton verklebt und
dann verschweißt ein Vorteil der
Plattenbauweise ist dass alle
Arbeitsschritte fast gleich sind das
spart ungemein viel Zeit
beim Einbau der Elemente kommt es vor
allem auf die Erfahrung des Kranführers
an die Arbeiter Vertrauen voll auf
seinen Fingerspitzengefühl im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes
bei allem was wir machen müssen wir uns
voll auf den Kranführer verlassen können
es ist extrem wichtig dass er immer voll
konzentriert ist und seinen Kran im
Griff hat
alle Teile sind extrem groß und schwer
und er darf unter keinen Umständen
irgendetwas beschädigen egal wie
stressig es auch ist
die Elemente müssen Zentimeter genau
ausgerichtet und eingesetzt werden sein
Job gehört zu den wichtigsten auf der
Baustelle ohne einen guten Kranführer
geht es nicht
die Kranführer sind wie fast alle
Arbeiter auf der Baustelle schon seit
ihrer Lehrzeit bei der Baufirma
beschäftigt anders als auf vielen
anderen Baustellen wo häufig
Saisonarbeiter eingesetzt werden wissen
die Leute hier genau wie wichtig
Erfahrung und Zusammenhalt auf einer
Turbo Baustelle wie dieser sind
und das zahlt sich wieder einmal aus
trotz widriger Umstände kommen die
Männer mit dem Dach gut voran und können
zum Ende ihrer Schicht Vollzug melden
der achte Stock ist fertig die
Spätschicht kann nun mit dem neunten
Stockwerk beginnen
auch für diese Etage sind nur drei Tage
vorgesehen bei konventioneller Bauweise
würde man dafür sehr viel länger
brauchen
das ist immer wir haben hier ein
ausgeklügeltes System es gibt drei
Schichten eine früh spät und
Nachtschicht in jeder Schicht gibt es
einen Vorarbeiter der verantwortlich ist
und jeder Arbeiter hat eine spezielle
Aufgabe und nur die erledigt der für
jede noch so kleine Arbeit gibt es eine
Person die zuständig ist
[Musik]
das beschleunigt den Prozesse nahm jeder
weiß genau was er zu tun hat
so vermeiden wir Chaos
ein weiterer Vorteil dieses System ist
weniger Personal intensiv eine Schicht
besteht aus nur sieben Arbeitern
der Bau geht weiter
trotz des harten russischen Winters
wächst das Hochhaus unaufhaltsam weiter
die Zeit drängt denn der Wohnungsmangel
ist in Moskau zu einem Politikum
geworden
alle drei Tage werden auf dieser
Baustelle 12 Wohnungen fertiggestellt
insgesamt 700 Quadratmeter Wohnfläche
die Baufirma hat nur noch sechs Tage bis
zur Übergabe
alle bewohnbaren Geschosse sind bereits
fertiggestellt jetzt fehlt nur noch das
Hausdach
[Musik]
die letzte große Herausforderung ist das
Technikgeschoss das auf dem Dach
installiert wird hier ist die
Gebäudetechnik untergebracht etwa das
lüftungs- und Heizungssystem oder die
Aufzugstechnik das Bauteam installiert
spezielle Mauerelemente mit großen
Öffnungen in der Mitte durch diese
verlegen die arbeiterkabel und die
Rohrleitungen zudem kann die Luft durch
die Öffnungen besser zirkulieren was
einen Hitzestau unter dem Dach
verhindern soll
die Deckenhöhe im Technik Geschoss
beträgt nur 1,50 m die Außenmauern sind
doppelt so hoch und bieten dadurch einen
Fallschutz für das Flachdach eine
gesetzliche Vorschrift die für alle
Hochhäuser in Russland gilt
aus Sicherheitsgründen dürfen die
Techniker erst mit der Arbeit beginnen
wenn das letzte Wandteil positioniert
ist
die Bauarbeiter müssen ein letztes Mal
aufs Tempo drücken
zum Glück ist es in den letzten Tagen
wärmer geworden so dass Sie keine
wertvolle Zeit mit Schneeschippen
verlieren
Bauarbeiter sehr gambert King
koordiniert welche Teile der Kran
hochheben muss
die nächsten Teile sind angekommen
genauso wie im Plan vorgesehen wir
können Sie gleich einbauen
die Männer haben nur noch zwei Tage Zeit
um die Wand und Deckenelemente zu
montieren
erst dann können die Installateure mit
ihrer Arbeit im Technikgeschoss beginnen
wofür ihnen sechs Tage bleiben
bis auf ein paar Kleinigkeiten ist die
Arbeit im Innern des Hochhauses fertig
die Sprinkleranlage die Heizungsrohre
und die Wasserleitungen sind in allen
Etagen installiert
Projektleiter Aspern sofianov bereitet
die Übergabe des Gebäudes an die
Eigentümer vor dafür inspiziert er
nochmal jedes einzelne Zimmer des 9000
Quadratmeter Gebäudes
[Musik]
während die verputzerinnen letzte
Schönheitsfehler im Innern beseitigen
setzen die Arbeiter ganz oben die ersten
Dachelemente ein
runter
Angestellte der Baufirma installieren
jeden Tag hunderte dieser vorgefertigten
Elemente auf verschiedenen Baustellen
rund um Moskau
wir haben nicht mehr ganz eine Woche
alles lief sehr gut und genau wie
geplant
in zwei Wochen fangen wir mit dem
nächsten Projekt an und so geht's dann
weiter von einer Baustelle zur nächsten
die Baufirma ist eine der größten und
ältesten in Russland seit ihrer Gründung
1961 haben ihre Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter 57 Millionen Quadratmeter
Wohnfläche geschaffen Wohnraum der
gerade in Moskau dringend gebraucht wird
Endspurt auf der mega-baustelle
[Musik]
und dann endlich fertig
trotz Lieferschwierigkeiten Kälte und
Winterstürmen hat das perfekt
eingestellte Team das gigantische Pop-Up
Hochhaus in nur 51 Arbeitstagen
fertiggestellt
dreimal schneller als bei
konventionellen Bauprojekten
guten Tag
alles ist fertig alles hat super
geklappt
ich bin wirklich glücklich über meine
Leute sie haben einen super Job gemacht
ich hoffe die zukünftigen Bewohner sind
auch zufrieden und werden gern hier
leben
sobald auch die Nachbargebäude fertig
sind können die neuen Bewohner einziehen
[Musik]
und das obwohl hier vor einigen Wochen
nur die Fundamente standen
[Musik]
30 Arbeiter und Arbeiterinnen Meister
ihres Fachs haben 51 Tage lang im
drei-schichtsystem alles gegeben sie
haben 10.000 Arbeitsstunden gebraucht um
das 14-stöckige 9000 Quadratmeter große
Hochhaus fertig zu stellen
dafür haben sie mehr als 1500
Wandelemente montiert
250 Tonnen Beton verbaut und mehr als 30
km Kabel verlegt
eine wirkliche Meisterleistung unter
zeitlichem hochdruck
[Musik]